so was wollte ich schon immer haben
einen mini basketball-meister leute
unglaublich wie lange das gedauert hat
das ist schwer etwas geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
wir haben heute folgendes vor und zwar
ihr wisst ja ich bin umgezogen
information gefahr seit zwei monaten
oder heute mal ganz kurz kommt ganz gut
hin seien ungefähr zwei monaten hier in
der wohnung und das ding weil ich hatte
hier die abstellkammer ich habe sehr
viele sachen aus köln noch mit
hingenommen und ich habe die letzten
tagen noch weiter ausgemistet und die
abstellkammer ein bisschen aufgeräumt
weil die war schon wieder voll
durcheinander von dabei habe ich noch
mega viele sachen gefunden die noch
nicht ausgepackt wurden die sich
irgendwann mal angeschaut haben in den
letzten zwei jahren 23 jahren waren auch
immer und ich habe mir gedacht bevor ich
die jetzt alle wegschmeißen packe ich
die wenigstens noch aus vielleicht ist
ja was cooles dabei und ja darum geht's
halt ich hoffe es wird cool ich würde
sagen gelacht und gar nicht lange let's
go ich habe hier keinen karton oder so
ein paket nennt man das eigentlich ganz
einfach mal verstaut box die kann man so
im schrank schieben und ja wir sind
komplett pakete drin und dann machen
wir's mal richtigen stelle gelaufen und
fakt eins nach dem andern aussagen
einfach mal hier wird ans netz gehe um
interessante handy hülle als dicker aber
mir fällt grad auf das ist keine normale
handy hülle
das ist eine geld backlight ab case
pulle also bis jetzt macht das für mich
nur den anschein als könnte man da sein
handy
die passt ja gar nicht verwechseln die
wissen dass ich probleme kurzfristig
macht den blitz an und halte es denn
hier so vor passiert da etwas besonderes
die gar keine ahnung man eigentlich
nicht mehr hacker so las ich habe
absolut keine ahnung was das bringen
soll wenn ihr es in die kommentare aber
für mich ist das nichts wir machen
weiter nächstes produkt das ist aber
auch alles eingepackt
warum jetzt daraus machen hier haben wir
eine led rgb bull mit remote control
also eine lampe led lampen kann man
irgendwo rein drehen und dann macht
vielleicht ne ruhig direkt weiter in die
lampe auch eigentlich gar nicht mal so
schlecht ich zeig euch das hier markt
moment das da ist ja meine
arbeitsbereich und da ist jetzt die
lampe die macht hier so schöne farben
das kann jeder lochore richtiges
blitzlicht party licht reicht jetzt auch
da frage ich mich warum habe ich die
eigentlich er ausgepackt okay was haben
wir hier noch mehr von diesen dingern
ich weiß dass ich das irgendwann mal ja
die habe ich schon mal vorgestellt keine
ahnung warum ich davon noch mehr
bekommen habe das ist wirklich absolut
ok wir haben hier noch mega viele handy
hüllen ich weiß gar nicht warum
eigentlich ich meine ich muss mir
irgendwas dabei gedacht haben als ich
die bestellt habe eine hier sind sogar
zwei drin einmal coca cola hier haben
wir eine nasa will fragt mich nicht ich
weiß nicht ich kann mich wirklich nicht
mehr daran erinnern was ich dir
irgendwann mal gekauft wird alt hat
jetzt wird es geil hier ist einfach
flanken ich habe das handy jetzt nicht
nur zwei monaten es ist einfach schon
kapiert deswegen lasse ich einfach mal
dieses stylische plankton hülle hier
darum das ist auf jeden fall bis jetzt
die coolste lasse ich mal darum wtf
alter was ist das ein alter das sind so
fitschen die kannst du ziehen und dann
geht das ding ning abmahnen gummiband
ist dabei das kann man dann hier einfach
einklemmen
boah alter das ist ja richtig ab ok was
haben wir hier noch das kenne ich
irgendwoher nähen hier haben wir einen
key feinde
also da hat sich der hersteller dabei
gedacht man hat ja oft das problem dass
man seinen schlüssel nicht findet oder
mit dem tief ein da findet man dem und
hier steht jetzt muss ich einfach nur
pfeifen und dann meldet sich dieses
gerät zurück das ist eine geniale
erfindung ich wusste gar nicht dass so
etwas gibt warten wir testen es noch mal
egal es funktioniert halt wirklich also
dass bald ich auf jeden fall ja ich kann
mich aber auch hier nicht daran erinnern
wann ich das mal gekauft
walter
sowas wollte schon immer haben einen
mini basketball set das gute ist ich
habe hier noch so einem spezialkleber
den kann man eine wand kleben auf unter
anderem also gut sollte man eigentlich
nicht aber für kurze zeit geht das mal
ich bin aber auch ich bin auch so ein
vollidiot hier sind ja schon so kleber
dabei die kannst du einfach abziehen
ich weiß ganz genau dass ich mir das ins
wohnzimmer hängen ich habe so auf den
drang mit einem ball zu spielen
den kannst du einfach immer entspannter
reinwerfen die haben wirklich an alles
gedacht wir haben hier sogar eine pumpe
bei mit nadel und jetzt kann ich hier
den basketball aufblasen und trevor
richards
da isser leute unglaublich wie lange das
gedauert hat das ist für schwere
flugzeug richtung hat gestimmt weiß ich
auch nicht nur euch das vorhin die
ausgeprägt sehr sehr geil
als nächstes haben wir hier ein 1 4 k
was das ok ach so das einfach nur ein
adapter den kann ich in meinem imac
stecken
ich denke ich habe so alsheimer ich weiß
wie ich weiß nicht wo das herkommt keine
ahnung
okay leute weitergeht
krawatte mal kurz ich glaube das gehört
zu dem alphabet ein video mit selina ich
weiß es aber gerade nicht genauer also
ich kann es nicht so ganz zu ordnen soll
meerjungfrauen kleid ja keine ahnung
kann ich auch nichts mit anfangen aber
mal so schlechte qualität ist das gar
nicht weiter gehts hier ist auf jeden
fall was extrem schweres trumm buches
ist das denn
ich mache einfach mal nur eine auf wir
haben hier
ich glaube das ist eine
selbstverteidigungs waffe das ist
nämlich ultra shafir sieht aus wie eine
karte aber du kannst damit leute
umbringen ich weiß nicht ob das legal
ist ja ich habe schon mal einige waffen
bayerisch und jude und alldem schweiz
bestellt und einige davon konnte ich
nicht zeigen weil das war halt nicht
legal das hier ist denke ich selbst
legal so aber schon krass ey
es ist wirklich ultra scharf ihrer seite
also poliert den kanal cool leute eine
zigaretten airports hülle
wer braucht sowas nicht ich frage mich
wirklich also ohne scheiß ich weiß ich
hab selber mal ein video gemacht wo ich
airport cases ausgepackt habt aber wer
kauft so was außer ich das ding ist halt
einfach so sperrig ne ich weiß es nicht
wir machen weiter tik tok airports case
leute ich muss sagen der ist da drin ist
er gehört noch zu einem anderen video
das wollte ich jetzt nicht auspacken
deswegen belassen wir das erstmal hier
bald jetzt auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt
nichts unnötig weggeschmissen ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen
der basketballkorb des ultra light den
werde ich auf jeden fall behalten wir
sehen uns morgen 19 wieder gibt es neues
video da teste ich nämlich die
verrücktesten getränke die man hier in
deutschland bei amazon bestellen kann
aber nicht super gerne den kanal daumen
nach oben und das war es von mir
instagram alex w haut rein